Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to CASE: Animatronics
NOW-
I haven't played this in a while because things got away from me
but I don't think I can stand here too long to make an introduction about it
I gotta get over here and I gotta figure out how to get batteries into this GOD DAMN RADIO
If this even *is* the radio that I'm supposed to do
and I don't even know if that's what I'm supposed to do
I was a little confused
because the mechanics of the owl didn't seem to be very clear to me
And I don't know if that's just me being dumb
- which is a very big possibility when generally speaking about everything that I'm doing around this world -
Where did he go??
where did he go?
why is my- ooh hello
AAH! Batteries!
That might be something that I need!
Okay: Animatronics attack their own-
[thumping sound]
I SHOULDN'T BE HERE READING THIS
YOU GUYS CAN READ IT AND I GOTTA GET GOIN'
because death is upon me
and I have batteries and I need to get them to the radio.
Oh boy, okay
[quietly] Oh boy
[quietly] Okay
I don't hear Wolfy stimp stompin' around
Okay
How do I-
No!
That's not what I wanted!
Wait is that on-
That- Tha-
[Reads note]
Okay.
BUUUUUUUT I'm still conf- Ohh is that a code?
Wait
No, that's just some writing on that-
WELL I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
I don't know why everything's still blurry because it seems like the temp-
Oh no, the temperature's goin' up.
WHY is the temperature going up?
That's a good question.
I have noo...
Okay
So I'm in trouble
That's what-
[quietly] No
[quietly] easy
I'm in trouble.
Okay!
Okay, alright, don't know what that was
but I recognize it as a BAD sound
And I can't have completely forgotten how to play since then..
I could have sworn that was like the only-
That was like the only option
For-
...Hi?
[quietly] Okay
That was like the only option for-
-a radio, right?
At least that's what my assumption was!
I don't know where else there would BE a radio!
I've never even SEEN a radio!
I don't even know what a radio IS!
AH!
fukkin-
aah
That, uh-
(That, uH-)
See, it wasn't exactly the NOISE it made, it was just
suddenly there was a wolf there and I didn't hear any stimp steppin'
so I have no idea...
why THAT was that thing that that was
But okay.
So.
I'm guessing he's just sitting there because he's GUARDING something
And then OWL boy over there is guarding that
so use the battery pack to turn on the radio.
AGAIN I don't know exactly where the radio is if this isn't it
so there must be like a hand-held radio
somewhere...
else... in here...
Which, I can only imagine that means-
OH, he's still THERE!
Oh, that's lovely and delightful. Maybe he's gonna go the fuck away!
I don't have a code!
[quietly] 'Kay, so
Obviously this radio is-
Okay!
That's how you're gonna be!
Ya ssssack o' shit? Okay!
Alright then.
WOW!
Alright, so, he- I don't know how or why he got me
That didn't make much sense at all!
How did he go away before, but now, all of a sudden, he's bein'... a big... giant...
douche.. McNnnnnnnnnmmmmstupid?
Ooh! He's gone! Don't know why!
BUT he is gone.
My flashlight's about to run out of battery.
Okay, so grab the battery packs
so the radio that they're talking about HAS to be in the back area.
*THUD noise*
HEY!
Who?
Did?
Where?
Why?
Are you in there?
Oooh, he's in there, isn't he?
Okay.
That's why that happened.
But I should be alright
All things consiiiiiderrr- *Low thud noise*
OOOOHHHH!
HIIII!!!
Okay! This does not help. This does NOT help me.
Ohh, because I'm turnin' my back to Wolfy- ooh, that isss... *metal creaking noise*
[quietly] Okay
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, get in the closet!
I don't know if this is gonna help.
THIS IS NOT GoNNA HELP!
This is SOOOOO not gonna help.
SO not gonna help!
-Maybe!
Maybe... if I look at... uh...
D1?
D1, wait.. D1?
Oh, yeah, I thought it was on D1, it didn't make any sense.
Okay
There's gotta be something, like, back at the warehouse...
[quietly] Okay
He's zip zoppin'
Okay, I think he zip zopped away.
[quietly] 'Kay
He's definit-
FUCKIN'- HE'S RIGHT THERE! HE'S JUST STANDING THERE! HE'S CAMPING THERE!
LIKE AN ASSHOLE!
All that hiding for nothing!
I tried to hide better! Tried to- beh- buh
SCREW YOU BETTER!
Oh. Hi.
Uh oh, uh oH, UH OH, UH OH, UH OH, UH OH!
Open! Open! Close! Close! Clo-
[DEATH] AAHEEEeeeeeEEEeee
He's there. He's just lurking there. He is! He totally is!
He's just standing there only to get you if you go around that corner.
[quietly] So
So that's like... So that's like closed off.
[quietly] How do you get around it?
You just gotta lose him?
It's the only thing I can thing of and I'm about to die any- WOAH!
Wai- It was open! What! It was open??
WHAT THE SHIT!
Are you kidding me?
WHAT?
Okay...
So I guess he's moved now.
It's pretty good.
[quietly] 'Kay
[quietly] Oh jeez, oh jeez, don't get caught, don't get caught...
[quietly] Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, okay
I think I'm clear.
Am I clear?
Woah.
Ooh!
Lockpick?
Oh, oh Jesus
Oh jeez, oh, get in, in in in, there's a radio in here
Pleeeease let there be a radio in here!
PLEASE let there be a radio iN HERE!
Where's the god damn-
[sighs]
I was right there! I didn't even know about that!
Where is it?
Oh!
That is so minute. That is so incredibly minute.
Okay. That's not good.
Alright, where?
What?
Oh no
[quietly] Oh no
Hello, hi! Gimmie a check point!
Okay?
[quietly] Okay
So!
What I'm suppos-
*quieter screeching*
Okay?
I still don't know about the radio thing!
But apparently I've got some files and apparently there's a keycard on the BACK of one of the animatronics.
And I'm gonna GUESS-
-that it's the Owl
cuz he's the only one that you would be able to get around, I suppose.
Man that's gonna be CHAAALENGING
chaaallenging~
Okay, so what happened?
Did something break outta the... thing that was in here?
It better have given me a checkpoint because if it didn't, I'm gonna be veeery pissed.
Also, it's veeery dark.
It's darker than it used to be and also everything seems-
Everything seems to be going black.
So what I gotta do is I-
Oh, it's still in there. So that's good!
Maybe.
That IS good.
So that means thaaat
whaaat
[quietly] I really hope that saved
[quietly] It better have saved
So I gotta get a keycard from the back of one of the animatronics
Thinking the Owl
-Ooh
Hey friend! Oh!
Are you docile?
What?
[quietly] huh?
[quietly] Ooh, I can't see aaanythi-
[gasp] Hi. Okay. I gotcha. I gotcha.
Got it!
You're awfully calm
for being presented with such a conundrum.
So where was there another door with a keycard in it that I have NOT opened yet?
I don't remEMMMberrr
(Eugh)
[quietly] So
What- were there any other doors?
I don't- ooh! Hey, buddy.
How you doin'?
I don't remember there being another dooooor
Huh.
Oh, maybe-! Wasn't there one towards, like, on the other side of the metal fence?
There was another door where the keycard- man it is so hard to see.
There was another door, like on the other side of this one...
Had a keycard, maybe?
Is that it?
[quietly] I don't know
No, that's closed.
Wouldn't have been anything else back here, would there have been?
Maybe to unleash the beast that's in the box? The box of beast? The beast box?
[quietly] That door?
Nope, can't even pick that.
Looks like I'm STUCK.
There's no other door!
God damn it!
[quietly] I can't see anything
God damn it. Why is it-
[quietly] What?
I'm dy- I'm dying, aren't I?
This is me dying!
From... suffocation!
What the hell...?
What?
Wha...
Hi!
Woah! Okay...
Wha-
Where's it gonna send me back??
Oh okay, at least it's here.
But I'm still confuuuused!
Woah!
Well, hi! Okay-
Well that was inconvenient for me!
You see how he- that- that- that fucked me?
No, okay I'm outta here.
Aaahhhhh'm fucked. I am- I am the Fucked™
[quietly] I went the wrong way
Oh boy
Wha-
What happened to my golden opportunity of them being all deactervaded...
Is that just not a thing anymore?
Am I just
I have to deal with this now.
Yeah- I-
I think I gotta just DEAL with it.
This is...
This is not cool.
Oh.
Well you don't have it anymore!
What!
but *I* don't have it!
[loudly] You don't have it, and I don't have it, and we don't have it, and what's going on?
I am so confused...
Oh.
Oh YOU have it now!
[In-Game] Looks like it's the keycard for some door...
[quietly] Some door.
[quietly] I don't know which door.
[In-Game] Damn! The card isn't compatible with that door.
No, it's not, is it?
It wouldn't be THAT easy!
And also everything is going dark again!
And they're gonna power back up, and then...
...nimmle my buttcheeks off.
Just kill me. Just kill me! Kill me!
Okay, I am utterly confused as to what to do. And also!
I am like physically ill!
I can't keep doing this because the vision with the- the thing going on!
Did I get a CODE at any time? I don't remember! And there's no note system so how would I even know?
There isn't a note system. I'm not just talkin' out of my ass about that.
The-There's not a note system!
So how am I-
There's like no journal, there's no recollection, there's just this tablet-
-And everything that you've got on your person!
And he's gonna eat me because apparently that's the curse that *I* have!
In this place!
MAN!
Aw man.
[sigh]
So, either way, that's all I'm gonna do for now and then I'm gonna try to finish this up in just one more episode
So again, sorry for the delay, I wanted to get to this sooner but life gets in the way sometimes. So-
THANK YOU EVERYBODY SO MUCH FOR WATCHING!
Let me know... what I'm supposed to do or how to solve the-
Wha-What's the CODE?
HOW DO I NOT DIE?
I don't know, I'll figure it out.
So thank you everybody, again. And as always, I will see YOU-
-in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!